[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه والتي نستهلها بالعناوين
هيات الانتخابات التركيه تعلن عدم وجود
فائز وتقرروا جوله اعاده بعد فشل اردوغانو
في تحقيق الاغلبيه
كيف تحصلوا على اسلحه جديده من بريطانيا
وروسيا تنتقد الصفقه وتعلن اعتراض
الصواريخ ستور شادو لاول مره
المعارك في السودان تدخل شهرها الثاني
والصليب الاحمر يحذر من قرب انهيار القطاع
الصحي
استدعاء عمران خان الى المحكمه من جديد
للرد على اتهامات بشان اعمال عنف
واحتجاجات ضد قرار الافراج
اهلا بكم اعلن الرئيس هيئه الانتخابات في
تركيا احمد ينير اللجوء الى جوله اعاده
لحسم الانتخابات الرئاسيه لاول مره في
تاريخ تركيا ستكون جوله الاعاده المقرره
في الثامن والعشرين من مايو بين رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي حصل على
49.51 من الاصوات ومرشح المعارضه كمال
كالجدار اوغلو الذي حصل على
44,88
بعد فرز مئه في المئه من الصناديق قال يار
ان كلا المرشحين يمكنهما بدء الدعايه
الانتخابيه على الفور وفقا لنتائج
اعتقد انها انتخابات مثيره للغايه تابعت
نتائج حتى وقت متاخر ربما سيكون لدينا
جوله ثانيه والمرشح الرئاسي الثالث سنان
اوغان سيتحالف مع الرئيس الحالي ويفوز
اردوغان
النتائج كما توقعنا في 28 من مايو اذا حقق
ار التوقعات فسيفوز بالانتخابات
سعيده بصفه ناخبه هناك استقطاب شديد
وتضارب في تنافس الجانبين انا قلقه بشان
مستقبل تركيا ساصل اردنا ان تفوز المعارضه
لكن سنرى ما سيحدث في الجوله الثانيه
نشر كمال المرشح لرئاسه التركيه مقطع
فيديو على حسابه على تويتر وقال انه
سيقاتل حتى النهايه على حد وصفه
كشفت الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه عن فوز
اردوغان باحدى وخمسين مقاطعه مقابل 30
مقاطعه لمرشح المعارضه كمارك في تفاصيل
ذلك خسر اردوغان اهم مقاطعتين هما اسطنبول
وانقره بعد انتصار كلجدار اوغلو فيهما
بفارق ضئيل كذلك تمكن مرشح المعارضه من
السيطره على جميع المقاطعات في شرق تركيا
تقريبا وبعض الولايات في الجنوب الغربي
بينما سيطر اردوغان على مقاطعات الوسط
والشمال ابرزها واكبرها مقاطعه كونيا كان
لافتا ايضا فوز كاليفجار اوغلو في بعض
الولايات التي تضررت بنكبه الزلزال مثل
هاتاي واضنه بينما فاز اردوغان في ولايه
اخرى متضرره كاشانلي اورفا وغازي عنتاب
على كل المعنى من غازي عنتاب موفد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر اهلا بك يعني
تصدر رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تصدر
نتائج تحديدا في غازي عنتاب نحو 60% هل
تضعنا اولا في اجواء النتائج في غازي
عنتاب
الان بالفعل وتصدر النتائج هنا بغزي عنتاب
بنسبه 60% مقارنه مع مع غريمه
كمال
ساقرا النتائج
بالتحديد مثلما
يعني تم الاعلان عنها هنا بغازي عنتاب حيث
حصل على
59.8 قرابه 60% مقارنه مع
34.6 بالمئه
بعد الانتهاء من عمليه الفرز لمئه في
المئه لصناديق الاقتراع هنا بغازي عنتاب
الحديث الان هنا في في غازي عنتاب وحتى في
المناطق الجنوبيه بالخصوص المتضرره من
الزلزال يدور حول استعدادات الجوله
الثانيه المعلنه من قبل هيئه الانتخابات
رغم هذه النتائج محققه لحزب العداله
والتنميه وزعيمه رجب طيب اردوغان الا انها
لم تحسم المعركه في الجوله الاولى ولم
يتصدر طبعا النتائج
ولم يتاهل
وهذا ما يدخل
تعتبر من ابرز المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال الماضي يعني الكل يتساءل كيف نجحت
مناطق تضررت بالزلزال نجح فيها اردوغان
بتحقيق هذه النسب العاليه نتحدث عن 60% في
هذه المناطق يعني رغم انه جميع الانتقادات
التي كانت موجهه للحكومه وللتقصير الحكومي
هل من وعود حكوميه ادت الى ذلك
بالفعل هناك كان كانت وعود للرئيس اردوغان
وحكومته باحتواء الازمه وكان هناك تقصير
ايضا في بدايه الكارثه واستغل ذلك كورقه
للمعارضه ضربت بها الحكومه وضربوا بدات
حملتها الدعائيه مبكرا حتى قبل تحديد موعد
الانتخابات الذي جرى بالامس اي 14 من مايو
لكن الناخبين بداوا يعني موضوعيين في
التعامل مع حكومه اردوغان ومع اردوغان
انفسها يعني نفسه فكان هناك تباين وتقارب
كبير جدا في النتائج على الاقل في المدن
الاكثر تضررا والمدينه التي كانت هي معقل
للمعارضه هاتاي الامس يعني قمت بتغطيه
منها تاي النتيجه بهاتاي يعني الفارق بين
المعارضه و رجب طيب اردوغان ليس بكبير جدا
يعني
48 في
لاردوغان ويعني 51 فقط بالمئه
فيما ذهب
ذهبت النسبه المتبقيه لسنان اوغان فهذا
يدل على ان المواطنين والناجين من الزلزال
والمتضررين يامنون ولديهم ثقه في الوعود
التي اطلقها رجب طيب اردوغان لاحتواء
تبعات الازمه والاثار التي خلفها خلفها
الزلزال المدمر باعاده اسكان المتضررين
حتى وان الاشواط احتواء هذه الازمه لم
تعرف تقدما كبيرا حسب معايناه فيها تاي
المتضرره بشكل كبير غير ان هناك انطباع
شبه يعني سائد لدى الناجين بان الاشهر
القادمه ستاتي لهم بماء يعني يسد رمقهم من
مطالب ومن حاجيات لعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها على الاقل فيما يتعلق
بالبناءات والمساكن التي وعد بها رجب طيب
اردوغان في حين المعارضون الناقمون على
سياسه الحكومه في معالجتها لهذه الازمه
قدموا اصواتهم للمعارضه
السيناريو عبد القادر خلال الجوله الثانيه
من هذه الانتخابات شكرا جزيلا
العربيه عبد القادر خربوش شكرا لك
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حيث 295 مقعدا عام 2023
تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حجم 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاز 67
مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعدا
في وقت ينصرف فيه المرشحان لتحضير لجوله
الاعاده اكد المرشح الرئاسي الحاصل على
المركز الثالث سنان اوغن انه مستعد
للتفاوض مع اردوغان وكالجدار اوغلو لدعم
احدهما في الجوله الثانيه من هذه
الانتخابات قال ان مواجهه الارهاب واعاده
اللاجئين اهم نقاط التفاوض مع اردوغان
وكريستارنه مستعد لدعمك اذا امتنع عن
تقديمي تنازلات للاكراد الا انه اعتبر ان
مرشح تحالف المعارضه لم ينجح في اقناع
الشعب
شروطه لترجيح كفه اردوغان او كليتش
داروغلو
مرهون بعدم تقديمه تنازلات للاكراد
القوميون الاتراك والا اتاتوركيون ستكون
لهم كلمه حاسمه في جوله الاعاده
سنتشاور مع قاعده ناخبين قبل التوصل لقرار
حول جوله الاعاده
على كل المعاي من اسطنبول زائد جول لرئيس
تحرير تركيا اهلا بك في العربيه اردوغان
الذي لم يهزم في عشر انتخابات وطنيه منذ
2003 لم ينجح في تامين الاصوات لحسم
الجوله الاولى لصالحه وكذلك خصمه في
المعارضه كالجدار اوغلو رغم كل ائتلاف
الكبير غير المسبوق للمعارضه التركيه في
الطاوله السداسيه الى انه كذلك لم ينجح في
حسم الجوله الاولى ما هي المعايير التي
منعت احد المرشحين في حصن الجوله الاولى
للصالحين
يعني بدايه التحيه الطيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدي قناتكم لا شك ان معادله النصف زائد
هي معادله جديده على الساحه السياسيه
التركيه
والحصول على الاصوات الفائز بالامس كان
يحتاج الى قرابه ما لا يقل عن 27 28 مليون
صوت تحديدا حسب نسب المشاركه وبالتالي
الحصول على هذا الرقم
الضخم كبير الكبير للغايه اعتقد انه امر
صعب للغايه لكلا المرشحين ابتداء وانتهاء
ويعني من البدايه حقيقه كان هناك اعتراضات
على هذا النظام بحد ذاته من قبل المعارضه
التركيه لان لا يمكن لاحد حتى سيد اردوغان
اضطر وهو الذي تحدث ان النظام الرئاسي لا
يحتاج الى
ائتلافات او تحالفات لكنه في نهايه المطاف
اضطر
تدخال خمسه احزاب سياسيه اخرى معه حتى لو
كانت هذه الاحزاب صغيره ضمن التحالفه وحتى
ضمن قوائمه من اجل ان يحصل على هذه النسبه
التي حصلها بالامس ولم يستطع بطبيعته
الحال التجاوز عتبه الخمسين وبالتالي ربما
يعني سيعاد صياغه هذا القرار او القانون
في قادم الايام وهو نقطه بالمناسبه اشار
اليها السيد اردوغان بالامس بشكل طفيف طيب
المرشح الرئاسيه ثالث الى اي مدى قد يكون
مفتاح الحسم في الجوله الثانيه وسيكون له
دور حاسم في تحديد هويه رئيس تركيا
للسنوات الخمس القادمه خصوصا في ظل نسبه
غير متوقعه ومفاجئه 5% حصل عليها في
الجوله الاولى
يعني من المؤكد ان سنانوجان هو اهم
الفائزين او اكبر الفائزين في انتخابات
الامس حيث حصل على قرابه كما قلتم 3 مليون
صوت تقريبا خمسه بالمئه من الاصوات او
اكثر بقليل وبالتالي هذه النسبه حقيقه هي
التي جعل او حرمت المرشحين من الوصول
لعتبه الخمسين هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه
الثانيه وهو الاهم انا لا اعتقد ان لديه
مفتاحا سحريا وليس لديه ما يستطيع ان
يقدمه للمرشحين الاثنين بشكل عام في جوله
الاعاده السيد سنان ليس لديه حزب سياسي
بالمفهوم التقليدي بمعنى اننا لا نتحدث عن
الاحزاب التركيه التقليديه التي لديها
تنظيمات ولديها تماسك ولديها ايديولوجيا
بغض النظر عن انها ستفوز او لا تفوز فان
قاعدتها الجماهيريه ستكون معها صادقه
فيها محسومه السيد سنان وناخبيهم من
الشباب الناقمين والغاضبين على العمليه
السياسيه وخطاب الحزب الحاكم من خطاب
السيد كمال الكوليسترول من جهه اخرى
وبالتالي هم لديهم ربما مطالب بسيطه مطالب
ليست استراتيجيه وليست بعيده المدى
النظام للاكراد الاجانب بشكل عام ايضا طيب
سيد زاهد 28 مايو جوله الاعاده ما المتوقع
منها
يعني حسب المعطيات الراهنه لا شك ان السيد
اردوغان سيكون هو الاوفر حظا لسببين اثنين
ابتداء انه يمتلك الاغلبيه البرلمانيه
يعني مع حلفائه وبالتالي من المؤكد ان
الذهاب او البقاء على الاستقرار السياسي
سيكون امرا مهما بالنسبه
لغالبيه المصوطين هذه نقطه اولى النقطه
الثانيه
المعارضه في اطروحاتها السياسيه
قدمت نفسها انها ستعمل على اعاده النظام
البرلماني الان الاستمتاع
بدعني اقول بصلاحيات النظام الرئاسي
والعمل بالنظام الرئاسي دونما اغلبيه
برلمانيه سيحرم المعارضه ابتداء وانتهاء
من كل اطروحاتها السياسيه
وخطابها السياسي خلال السنوات الماضيه انا
اعتقد ان السيد كمالكوليسترو يتح عليه
الان اذا كنا سنذهب الى جوله الاعاده ان
يقدم لنا كيف سيعمل بشكل واقعي وعملي على
اداره البلاد وهو رئيس للجمهوريه وليس
لديه اغلبيه برلمانيه كيف ستسير الامور
وكيف سيقود البلاد وكيف سيتعامل مع هذا
النظام الرئاسي وعلى على على اي اساس لان
هذا السيناريو حقيقه لم يكن مطروحا من قبل
المعارضه قبل هذه الانتخابات فاعتقد انه
يحتاج الى قصه جديده حتى يقنع ناخبيه
ابتداء وانتهاء قبل ان يقنع ناخبين جدد
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول زاهد جول رئيس
تحرير اندبندن تركيا شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
والخامسه مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
الكريم لن ينتقدوا حول العلاقات بين موسكو
والصين
اهلا بكم من جديد اكدت بريطانيا تزويد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى طلبتها
لقتالها ضد القوات الروسيه بحسب وزير
الدفاع البريطاني بين الصواريخ من نوع توم
شادو ستمنح لاوكرانيا وستمنحها افضل فرصه
للدفاع عن نفسها
صواريخه ستور مشادو من نوع جو ارض بعيده
المدى مداها اكثر من 250 كيلومترا مقارنه
بصواريخ هاي مارس التي زودتها بها
الولايات المتحده بمدن لا يتجاوز 80
كيلومترا يتم اطلاق الصواريخ من الطائرات
ما يعني ان الطيارين الاوكرانيين سيكونون
قادرين على البقاء بعيدا عن الخطوط
الاماميه هذا وقد زودت بريطانيا اوكرانيا
مسبقا بمعدات عسكريه اخرى منها اربع عشره
دبابه تشالنجر 2 في يناير الماضي وطائرات
بدون طيار من نوع مالويتي 150 القادره على
التحليق لسته وثلاثين دقيقه ويتم التحكم
فيها من قبل جندي عبر حاسوب
استبعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك
وجود خطط لارسال مقاتلات لاوكرانيا خصوصا
انها تفضل استخدام مقاتلات اف 16
الامريكيه اكد سوناك خلال لقائه مع
بريطانيا ستكون من ضمن تحالف الدول التي
ستدرب الاوكرانيين على استخدام الطائرات
الحربيه قريبا
المتحدث باسم الكريم
اوكرانيا باسلحه اضافيه اضاف بيسكوف ان
هذا لن يؤثر على مسار العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه كما قال المتحدث باسم
الكرملين ان موسكو تقيم هذا بشكل سلبي
للغايه اضاف ان تزويد لندن بالاسلحه سيؤدي
الى مزيد من الدمار في العلاقات بين
البلدين
المانيا كانت اعلنت انها ستزود اوكرانيا
بحزمه مساعدات تقارب ثلاثه مليارات دولار
لتعزيز دفاعها عن البلاد في اكبر تعهد
لبرلين في تقديم مساعدات عسكريه منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الالمانيه الحزمه قد تشمل مجموعه
متنوعه من المعدات العسكريه بما في ذلك
ناقله جند مدرعه بالاضافه الى 30 دبابه
اليوبارد وطائرات استطلاع بدون طيار
وذخيره هذا وقد زودت المانيا اوكرانيا في
ابريل الماضي بانظمه شيبارد المضاده
للطائرات
القوات الروسيه كانت اعترضت خلال الاربع
من العشرين ساعه الماضيه صاروخا اوكرانيا
بعيدا المدى من طراست الذي تسلمته كييف من
لندن قبل ايام حيث اكد بيان الدفاع
الروسيه ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطت سبعه
صواريخ هارب مضاده للرادار وصاروخ كروس
طويل المدى من طرازته وعشر مقذوفات اخرى
من صواريخ مارس المتعدده
على كل من دبي انضم الينا عبر زوم رياض
قهوه جلبه في الشؤون الامن والدفاع الصيد
رياض اهلا بكم معنا في العربيه بريطانيا
كانت اعلنت انها اول دوله تسلم اوكرانيا
صواريخ بعيده المدى من طراز كروس
ستورمشادو اهميه هذه الترسانه العسكريه
التي حصلت عليها اوكرانيا حتى الان من
الغرب نتحدث عن كذلك مسيرات حربيه وصواريخ
مضاده للطائرات واليوم صواريخ بعيده المدى
يعني طبعا هذه الاسلحه هي من نوعين هناك
الاسلحه الدفاعيه
صواريخ المضاده للطائرات للدفاع ضد ايضا
الصواريخ البلاستيكيه او ضد الصواريخ
الجوال او المسيرات وهناك الاسلحه
الهجوميه مثل الصواريخ ستورم شادو مثل
المدرعات
عربيات عربيات الهجوميه طائرات المسيره
ايضا وبالتالي
الحزمه الاسلحه التي تتسلمها
اوكرانيا من الدول الاوروبيه لها
منافع متعدده ان كان في الدفاع او في
الهجوم انما جميعه ياتي في اطار التحضير
للهجوم الكبير المتوقع من جانب اوكرانيا
والصواريخ ستورم شادو ستمنح اوكرانيا
القدره على ضرب اهداف في العمق اي ان
تستطيع استهداف مخازن
اماكن تجمع القوات الروسيه في المناطق
الخلفيه وبالتالي هذا يزيد من استنزاف
الطرف الروسي ضرب اماكن التجمع مراكز
قياده والسيطره في الاماكن التي
يتركز هجوم المقبل عليها
موسكو رده وتقول ان هذه الترسانه لن تغير
شيئا في مسار العمليه العسكريه على الارض
استراتيجيا عمليا ومن الناحيه العسكريه
الى اماده هذه الترسانه العسكريه التي
حصلت عليها من الغرب قد تقلب موازين القوى
او ترجح الكفه لصالح كياف في تحقيق خرق او
اختراق للدفاعات الروسيه
نحن نشهد من بدايه هذه الحرب العجز الروسي
عن تحقيق النصر والاحتفاظ به شهدنا النجاح
في هجومهم الساحق في الصيف الماضي
استعادوا مساحات شاسعه
شهدنا تغلب الاله العسكريه الغربيه في
تفوقها في العديد من النواحي على الاله
العسكريه الروسيه وبالتالي كلام
الحكومه الروسيه اليوم والقوات الروسيه هو
اكثر منه واقع نحن نتكلم عن وقائع عن
الارض وليس فقط ناخذ بكلام ما يتم تصريح
به من جانب اوكرانيا وغيرها نحن نحكم
نتائج ما يجري على الارض ما يجري على
الارض ان هناك عجز واضح من الجانب الروسي
في تحقيق اي تقدم منذ فتره طويله وتمكن
اوكرانيا من استعاده مساحات مهمه من
الاراضي التي كانت احتلتها روسيا وهناك
اليوم تحضير لهجوم كبير
الجميع ينتظره شكرا جزيلا لك من عبر الزوم
رياض قهوج الباحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع
شكرا جزيلا
نفذ سلطات ودونيت كالمواليه لروسيا اي
تراجع للقوات الروسيه في بخموت مؤكده
مضيئه في السيطره على القطاع الغربي من
هذه المدينه اوكرانيا كانت تعلنت انها
حققت اول نجاح في هجومها في محيط مدينه
بخموت وتقدمت باتجاه الخطوط الدفاعيه
الروسيه الا ان رئيس سلطاد دونيتس قال ان
القوات الروسيه سيطرت على مرتفعات مهمه في
غرب موت وتتصدى لجميع الهجمات التي تشنها
القوات لاختراق الدفاعات هناك اضاف ان
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على ما يقارب من 90%
من اراضي بخموت لكن الوضع فيها يبقى
متوترا مع تكثيف في اوكرانيا هجماتها على
طول خطوط التماس
تعتبر المعركه للسيطره على مدينه باخموت
الواقعه الشرق اوكرانيا من قبل روسيا
لاشهر عديده هي الاطول والاكثر دمويه في
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه وفق توقعات
مسؤولين غربيين قتل او جرح ما بين عشرين
وثلاثين الف جندي روسي هناك بينما دفع
الجيش الاوكراني ثملا باهضا ومازال مستمرا
الرئيس الاوكراني
لقب حصن الروح المعنويه الاوكرانيه مشددا
على عدم الاستسلام هناك كما رجح محللوننا
جنوب اوكرانيا هو المكان الذي يتوقع
كثيرون ان يكون تركيز الهجوم الاوكراني
عليه وقد امرت روسيا بالفعل باخلاء جزئي
بالقرب من محطه الطاقه النوويه فيزا
باروشيا
من كييف ينضم الينا مراسل عربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه اهلا بك يبدو ان المعركه
الاعنف والاطوال تدور اليوم في جبهه
باخموت حيث تسيطر القوات الروسيه هناك على
اغلبيه المدينه اليوم تتحدث القوات
الروسيه عن تحقيق اول مكاسب واول نجاح كما
سمته حول بخموت اين اين حصل التقدم تحديدا
حذيفه وما اهميته
مساء الخير سهام في الحقيقه هي تحقق تقدم
ومكاسب لثلاثه ايام ولكنها اليوم فقط
اعلنت عن ذلك الثلاثه ايام الماضيه شهدت
تقدم من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه التي
استطاعت ان تستعيد السيطره على 17 كيلو
مترا مربعا في مدينه بخموت وهذا رقم كبير
بالنسبه للفتره الماضيه حتى ان القوات
الروسيه كانت دائما تتقدم حوالي 100 متر
مئتين متر في اليوم ولكن في ثلاثه ايام ان
تستطيع ان تتقدم
وتستعيد السيطره على عشره مواقع روسيه وهو
مساحته 17 كيلو مترا هذا رقم كبير ينظر
الخبراء الى ان هذا هو الهجوم المضاد
الغير معلن من قبل السلطات الاوكرانيه قد
بدا بالفعل في باخ الجبهه الاعنف والاشرس
طبعا اهميه هذه الجبهه تحدثت كثيرا عن ان
جبهه باخوتي هي الاهم بالنسبه لها لانها
ممسك بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه من توسيع
الجبهه في جبهات اخرى خلاف دون اسكو
تحديدا خلاف باخت ذلك لتركيز القوات
الروسيه على هذه الجبهه هذه الجبهه اذا
استطاعت القوات الروسيه ان تخترقها تستطيع
ان تسيطر على كامل الحدود الاداريه
لما تبقى من لوغانست ثم بعد ذلك تتقدم في
اتجاهات اخرى اما خارقه او اخر سون او
زبروزا والتقدم حتى من الشمال نحو العاصمه
كيف لذلك كانت بالنسبه لها هذه الجبهه
مهمه جدا كان هنالك طبعا
لاختراق دفاعات القوات الروسيه طيب حذيفه
يقال انه هذا التقدم الكبير الذي تحققه
والاستراتيجي القوات الاوكرانيه بسبب
ترسانه السلاح التي حصلت عليها كيف من
الغرب هناك اليوم جوله اوروبيه لرئيسكي
اليوم في بريطانيا هل من تفاصيل اوفى حول
هذه الزياره التي يسعى من خلالها الى
الحصول على السلاح
نعم في الحقيقه هو حصل بالفعل على مئات من
الطائرات الهجوميه المسيره طبعا الطائرات
دون طيار الهجوميه وهذا يعني هذا امر يحدث
لاول مره دائما حتى قبل هذا الربيع حتى
نهايه الخريف كان يصر الغرب على ان يعطي
كييف اسلحه دفاعيه فقط وليس هجوميه ولكن
الان كما تفضلت قبل قليل بالصواريخ وكذلك
الطائرات الهجوميه المسيره التي ستحصل
عليها كيف الان هذه الطائرات تسمح لاكييف
بالضرب في عمق تواجد القوات الروسيه وضرب
طبعا المستودعات للسلاح والذخيره وما الى
ذلك وذلك يمكن ان يغير المعركه تماما الان
كيف تحاول ان تستعيد الاراضي ولذلك سوف
تقوم بهجوم هذا الهجوم المضاد يحتاج ان
تقطع طرق الامداد في الخلف يحتاج ان تدمر
مستودعات الذخيره وما الى ذلك وحتى ترى
صارت الجنود والاسلحه التي تتقدم نحو
الجبهه لذلك هنالك اهميه كبيره لهذه
الاسلحه ايضا ستحصل طبعا على المئات من
الصواريخ مضادات
الطيران والدفاع الجوي لحمايه المدن
الاوكرانيه من الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه
اضافه الى المسيرات الحربيه شكرا منك
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك
في كشف هو الاول من نوعه قالت وثائق
واستخبارات هي امريكيه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني
كان يخطط لتوسيع الحرب خارج حدود البلدين
وصفه اياب صاحب الغرائز العدواني على عكس
ما يظهر كرجل دوله هادئ ورصين تفاصيل في
هذا التقرير
ربما حاز هذا الرجل على تعاطف كبير خلال
الحرب في بلاده لكن وثائق الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تقول انه يتمتع بغرائز عدوانيه
تتناقض مع صورته كرجل دوله هادئ ورصيد
فالرجل وفقا للوثائق اراد ان يذهب في حربه
مع روسيا ابعد من حدود بلاده ليس فقط داخل
روسيا بل الى حد استهداف مصالحها على بعد
الاف الاميال في اجتماع عقد في يناير
اقترح زيلينسكيشن ضربات في روسيا واحتلال
مدن حدوديه روسيه تمنح كييف نفوذا في
المحادثات مع موسكو وفي اجتماع ثان اقترح
زيلينسكي هجوما على مواقع غير محدده في
راستوف غرب روسيا باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار اجتماع اخر عقد مع نائبه رئيس
الوزراء
الرجل تفجير خط انابيب دروج بالسوفيتي
الذي يمد المجر بالنفط
كانت قد منحت زيلينسكي اسلحه متطوره
بمليارات الدولارات لكن بايدن رفض طلبه
بالحصول على صواريخ اتاكس بعيده المدى امر
قد يعكس صدقيه ما تتحدث عنه الوثائق من
عدوان
وفقا لاحدى الوثائق فان المخابرات
الاوكرانيه وضعت خضتنا العام الفائت لشن
هجمات سريه على القوات الروسيه في سوريا
باستخدام مساعده كرديه سريه العمليه كانت
ستفتح ساحه معركه جديده على بعد الاف
الاميال من اوكرانيا لكن زيلنسكي امر
بالغاء الخطه دون توضيح الاسباب مؤخرا
زودت بريطانيا كيف بصواريخ ستوم شادو التي
تتمتع بقدرات التخفي ويصل مداها 155 ميلا
سرعان ما اعلن الكرملين انها ضربت الاراضي
الروسيه واصابت
مدنيينسكي نافاميرا نيته ضرب الاراضي
الروسيه باسلحه غربيه
بينما تقول التسريبات انه كان ليفعلها
وياخذ اوروبا الى تصعيد جديد رائد المصطفى
العربيه
نطق باسم الكرم لاند متري بيسكو تصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون حول
العلاقات بين موسكو والصين قال بيسكو في
ناموسكو لا توافق ابدا باريس في رايه حول
تبعيه روسيا للصين موضحا ان العلاقات مع
الصين ذات طابع شراكه استراتيجيه ولا
يرتبط باي تبعيه لطرف ما
دخول الصراع في السودان شهره الثاني شهدت
البلاد تطورات ميدانيه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع حيث اتهم الاخير قوات
الجيش بشن هجمات جويه على مناطق ماهوله
بالمدنيين بالعاصمه الخرطوم بالاضافه الى
استهداف مستشفى شرق النيل قالت قوه الدعم
السريع ان هذا الهجوم ادى الى مقتلي
واصابه العشرات من المواطنين وتدمير جزء
كبير من المستشفى
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر قالت من
جهتها ان المرافق الصحيه في السودان على
وشك الانهيار اضافه اللجنه ان مرافق
الرعايه الصحيه في السودان تعاني من
اسابيع منذ اسابيع من نقص الامدادات
والعلاج مشيره الى توقف اكثر من 70% من
المستشفيات عن العمل
شهر على الحرب في السودان ولا مخرج في
الافق فالسودان قبل الحرب كان غارقا اساسا
في فوضى سياسيه واقتصاديه وبات البلد مهدد
بالانهيار حتى الان اوقعت الحرب اكثر من
750 قتيلا والاف الجرحى اضافه الى نحو
مليون نازح ولاجئ هناك 45 مليون مواطن
يعيشون في خوف ويعانون من ازمات غذائيه
تصل الى حد الجوع مع محاذير امميه من ان
الجوع سيطال 19 مليون سوداني في غضون سته
اشهر اذا استمرت هذه الحرب قبل الحرب كان
ثلث من سكان البلاد يعتمدون على المساعدات
الغذائيه الدوليه اليوم اصبحوا محرومين
منها فمخازن المنظمات الانسانيه نهبت كما
علقت وعلقت الكثير من هذه المنظمات عملها
بعد مقتل 18 من موظفيها اما بالنسبه
للبنوك فاصبحت السيوله نادره فيما سجلت
الاسعار ارتفاعا حاده وصل الى اربعه اضعاف
بالنسبه للمواد الغذائيه وعشرين ضعفا
بالنسبه للوقود
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على كل معانا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان لنا يعقوب لين اهلا
بكيه معنا في الاستوديو اهلا بك يا سهام
طيب لينا لو نسال اولا عن الوضع الانساني
عن احوال الناس في بيوتهم في ظل حديث عن
نقص حاد وشديد في المواد الغذائيه في
الادويه وفي الحاجات الاساسيه الوضع ما
زال معقد خاصه مع استمرار الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في بحر ام درمان
والخرطوم هناك انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي
وللمياه في كثير من احياء بحري وكذلك في
بعض المناطق في الخرطوم ومن درمان هناك
عدم قدره للحركه هناك تفتيش كبير ايضا من
نقاط ارتكاز للدعم السريع للمواطنين طبعا
المستشفيات كما نعلم جميعا قوات الدعم
السريع تتواجد في كثير من مستشفيات
العاصمه او حولتها لثقنات عسكريه الامر
الذي قد يجعل الجيش يستهدف ايضا هذه
المناطق والمناطق المحيطه بها فهذا يعني
استمرار الاشتباكات في مناطق خدميه طبعا
محطات المياه الكهرباء هناك تذبذب لخدمه
الانترنت وكذلك الاتصالات لبعض الشبكات في
اوقات متقطعه هذا يعني ان الاوضاع
الانسانيه صعبه مع احتمال ان يحدث شح في
الغذاء في كثير من المناطق التي لا تستطيع
العربات طبعا والشركات الوصول اليها
عن الجيش السوداني طه الاخبار اليوم كذلك
سلسله الاقالات التي اجراها البرهان اخرها
لمحافظ البنك المركزي ما سبب هذه الاقالات
يبدو انني رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد
العام للجيش السوداني معلومات فيما يتعلق
بمحافظه بنك السودان خاصه اننا قد نربط
هذه الاقاله مع تجميد حسابات الدعم السريع
وقائد الدعم السريع في الخارج هذا يبدو ان
الامر مرتبط بتحويل الاموال كما ان كثير
من الناس طبعا لم تتحول المرتبات صحيح ان
كثير من التطبيقات والبنوك لا تعمل ولكن
هناك حاجه ماسه للمواطنين للحصول على
اموالهم بالتالي لم تكون هناك اي حلول من
بنك السودان لهذا الامر هناك تحفظات على
اداء عمل الشرطه فيما يتعلق باقاله مدير
عام الشرطه والذي يشغل ايضا وزير الداخليه
المكلف هناك تحفظات لعدم انتشار القوات
الشرطيه في كثير من المناطق بما فيها
المناطق الامنه وهذا ايضا اثر بصوره
مباشره هناك اعفاءات ايضا لسفراء فهناك
ملاحظات على اداء الحكومه خلال فتره هذه
الحرب شكرا جزي لا لكي كنتي معنا هنا في
الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه في السودان
يعقوب شكرا لينا شكرا
والخامسه مستمره وفيها
اعصار قوي يضرب ميا مار ويتسبب بمقتل
واصابه المئات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد استدعت المحكمه رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران للرد
على الاتهامات الموجهه اليه بعد اعتقاله
واحتجازه الاسبوع الماضي بشان التخطيط
لاعمال العنف التي اعقب التوقيفه وتسببت
باندلاع اضطرابات داميه في مدن عده بين
انصاره والقوات الامنيه قال محمد دفاع
النخان سيمثل امام المحكمه لقضايا مسجله
ضده تتعلق بالاحداث من التاسع الى الثاني
عشر من مايو
هذا وقد توافد الاف المحتجين الباكستانيين
وشقوا طريقهم نحو مقر المحكمه العليا في
اسلام اباد لتنظيم اعتصام النادر ضد
قرارها بمنح رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان افراجا واعتبار اعتقاله باطلا على
خلفيه قضيه فساد حيث بدا المظهر امام
المحكمه مكتظا بالمدنيين والحافلات
والمركبات والسنتشار امنيا مكثف وتجمعت
الاحزاب المعارضه لعمران خان احتجاجا على
اطلاقه بكفاله وحمايته من الاعتقال حتى
اواخر الشهر
كشف سالم الجميل المدير السابق لشعبه
امريكا في المخابرات العراقيه في حوار مع
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط ان الرئيس الراحل صدام
حسين مول حملات انتخابيه للرئيس الفرنسي
السابق جاك شيراك كما كان له دور كبير في
تمويل عده اطراف سياسيه في دول عربيه
ومجاوره مثل لبنان وليبيا وباكستان
الى احدى محطات المترو الباريسيه وصل ضابط
عراقي بحقيبه فيها ملايين الدولارات
التقى باحد مساعدي جاك شيراك وسلمه المال
لتمويل حملته الانتخابيه
مشهد من التاريخ يعود لثمانينيات القرن
الماضي كشف عنه سالم الجميلي مدير شعبه
امريكا في مخابرات حزب البعث العراقي في
حوار مع صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
وكانت تسلم في في بترو
عريس الضابط مع الحقيبه
المبعوث اللي جاي من طرف واشيرك متفقين
على
معينه ويسلم الحقيبه وهذا تكرر اكثر من
مره مرتين
ما كشفه الجميلي سبق وان تحدث عنه الرئيس
السابق لجهاز الاستخبارات البريطانيه
السير ريتشاردير لوف ان الرئيس الاسبق
لفرنسا تلقى اموالا من صدام حسين لتمويل
حملاته الانتخابيه في عام
1995 وعام 2002 وهو ما جعل شيراك يعارض
غزو العراق
ومن فرنسا الى باكستان وصولا الى ليبيا
ولبنان حيث مول النظام العراقي السابق
بالمال والسلاح
وصارت المعركه كبد الحقيقه كبد السوريين
خسائر كبيره
يعني يمكن
جندي سوري
قتلوا في تلك الفتره يعني في الحقيقه
وظل يعني مشي العام في مركز قوه رحل صدام
حسين لكن اسراره باقيه
كشف منها القليل والكثير مازال طي الكتمان
[موسيقى]
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن رفض زعيم حركه
طالبان هبه الله اخوان زاد لقاء وزير
داخليته سراج الدين حقاني بعد انتظار
الاخير اسبوعين دون نتيجه ما يدلل على
اتساع الشرق في صفوف الحركه المزيد في هذا
التقرير
اسبوعين انتظر هنا وزير داخليه طالبان
سراج الدين حقاني للقاء الزعيم الحركه هبه
الله اخون زاده دون ان يفلح انتظار يمشي
بشرخ في اوساط الحركه مصادر العربيه قالت
ان اخ زاده رفض لقاء حقاني بعدما وجه
الاخير انتقادات اللاذعه للزعيم الحركه
بسبب ما سماه احتكار السلطه وتشويه سمعه
النظام يجب ان يكون الشعب بكل اطيافه
شريكا في الحكومه مؤسس طالبان الملا عمر
لم يؤسس الحركه لينقذ القاده انفسهم بل
انشا الحركه من اجل انقاذ البلاد حقاني
الذي ينحدر من ولايه بكتيا شرق افغانستان
لم يترك فرصه للعوده الى انتقاد الزعيم
الطالبان سيما بعد تاسيس اخون زاده قوه
امنيه خاصه من المقربين منه وابناء قبيلته
المصادر ذكرت في وقت سابق ان حقان يسعى
الى تشكيل مجلس للحكم داخل الحركه ضمن
لتقييد السلطات الزعيم طالبان هبه الله
اخون زاده الوزير الذي سعى الى الانفتاح
على الغرب والحصول على دعم المجتمع الدولي
في انقلاب الناعم على قياده قندهار رفض
حصر التعيينات في الحكومه برجال الدين
تصاعد الانتقادات للزعيم الحركه ياتي عقب
اوامره بنقل اركان الحكومه من كابول الى
قندهار واحكام السيطرته عليها بعد ان نقل
مكتب المتحدث الرسمي باسم الحركه ذبيح
الله مجاهد ورئيس مركز المعلومات والاعلام
الوطني الى المدينه نفسها اضافه الى نقل
كتيبتين القوات الخاصه بدر 313 وفاتح من
كابول الى مسقط راسه ايضا
قندهار لم تعلق على انتقادات لحقان لكن
حاكم قندهار السابق سبق ورد على الوزير
بقوله ان الطاعه واجبه على الجميع وان
الزعيم ماض في قرارات ه حتى لو عارضها
العالم باجمعه
[موسيقى]
اجلت فرق الانقاذ نحو الف شخص حصر بسبب
مياه البحر التي بلغ عمقها ثلاثه فاصله
سته امتار على طول الساحل الغربي لسيتووي
احدى ولايات مايان مارك بعد اعصار قوي ادى
لمقتل سته اشخاص واصابه المئات وبقوع
اضرار وقطع اتصالات
[موسيقى]
ونختم الخامسه لهذا اليوم شكرا لكم على
كرم المتابعه ودائما للمزيد من متابعه
ملفات العربيه على العربيه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات